hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the evil within - hi
how's it goin welcome back everybody or
should I say welcome back to myself I'm
right here
can't you see me I'm not late I'm not
late you're late
everything else is late except for me so
welcome everybody to the evil within -
thank you for joining me I know it's
been a while since the evil within one
or its many expansions and I know you
guys have been eagerly awaiting for me
to play this game but I'm finally back
from vacation I'm finally in my new
recording room and I'm finally able to
play this game with you right here live
so let's get into the game right now cuz
we have no further ado - wait for I
don't even know if I use that correctly
but I'm gonna keep pressing forward as
if I know what I'm talking about so the
evil within - oh for those who want the
basics of a survival horror experience
keep an eye on resources approach
situation with caution don't get
overconfident I'm exactly as confident
as I need to be for how great I am
what are you talking about recommend for
players who enjoyed the difficulty of
the I did enjoy the difficulty of the
previous game I will say that oh I will
say that ah alright okay alright maybe
maybe maybe maybe but it before I it
before I get underway I got a I got to
do one thing real quickly here I forgot
and there we go I think that's gonna be
good okay so what do you guys think hard
nightmare nightmare mode nightmare mode
might be I'd be the right way to go
about it but I'm not arms insurer so oh
okay all right okay all right a lot of
people want nightmare mode but also
I'm gonna go for it I'm gonna go for it
I know it's probably a mistake I know
it's probably a mistake home engulfed in
flames tragic fire kills child man oh
but that's horribly ironic oh no a fire
consuming the newspaper that they're set
a fire consumed the house of it oh no
yeah yeah okay we're going nightmare
we're going nightmare mode and I don't
know where it's gonna leave buses now I
see people like no don't do nightmare no
you fool
too big idiot listen to the sign it's
clearly there for your protection no no
this is not happening that it's clearly
happening what are you looking at of
course it's happening it's not a mistake
I know what I'm doing Oh whoo look at me
run go Sebastian did you think that that
was Lily just blowing up right there no
this is his this is Sebastian's past I
believe like his tragic backstory that
we were kind of touching on in the first
game but I'm not 100% sure all right
let's go this way
Lebowski damn it damn it damn my family
for being so secure and locking all the
doors I'm in good I'm in good I just got
back to vacation but let's take care of
this this situation first
yeah [ __ ] alright fine men well this is
no good
ooh backstory do they both have guns but
it what did I both have guns do you see
that in that painting they both have
guns there Oh
maybe is it because like they're both
officers wait no that was here wasn't
happening god I spent so long since I
played the original game but I put yeah
apparently but yeah that's right because
the his wife is still alive now I
remember
yeah because oh geez oh come on out what
Lily where are you I'm here dad's here
you weren't here from you dad
all righty then okay yeah I didn't I
knew that was gonna be bad look from the
very GetGo how his hand is still
bandaged up from when it got stabbed
well I mean it got stabbed and shot and
broken BRABUS hello hi how are you doing
hello Sebastian it's been a long time
three years I've been trying to track
you down for three years then you
thought you'd find me at the bottom of
an empty bottle is that it and why are
you here now damn it you didn't find me
because they didn't want you to calm
down Sebastian you knew what was gonna
happen in that hospital didn't you what
happened at vegan is in the past you
need to forget it you sound just like
that psychologist that force shoved down
my throat
but he didn't have answers you do you're
gonna tell me about Mobius yeah oh
that's probably not good I think those
guys are straight out of the matrix yeah
because of this did you get this you
know what
you know what's super weird Kidman looks
exactly like his daughter and I don't
know if that's intentional but Kidman
looks exactly like his daughter I'm not
the only one that sees that right I read
the police report I was at her funeral
we can rewrite history if we want to
staging a death is child's play
why would I come out of the shadows just
to lie to you Lily is alive and she's
with us but she's in danger we need you
to help save her
safer what have you done to her you
don't mess with Sebastian oh wow why
what did you do that to my pork neck
Lily needs you okay
his agent Smith and Agent Smith back
they're gonna help you with that okay my
thought is at the end of evil within one
it was never clear whether or not he was
out of the whole system right good oh
hello yeah oh oh no I'm in a chair y'all
mighty Moebius be careful about what you
say you don't know how powerful they are
I have an inkling cyber suspicions have
to kidnap a washed-up ex-cop to help
them at least your terrible sense of
humor is still intact terrible enough of
this [ __ ] where's Lily right - all
your answers are right here see ha ha I
called it I think she's a lily
Oh God not this wait no this was a
hospital it was an unfortunate setback
who's talking but we used the knowledge
gained to build a new and vastly
improved stem system and I don't like
that Oh was that harder imagine it
millions of minds connected together no
no thank you
happiness for one is happiness for all
that trickles down happiness going on
miracle will allow our species to
achieve greatness
no no no no we needed to start with a
mind that was pure and clean enough to
support thousands of personalities the
mind of an innocent child
you connected lily to that machine her
daughter is quite special the most
stable core candidate we've ever tested
thanks to her the new stem has been a
smashing success
until recently over a week ago
Lily vanished just stop sending signals
what's this turn right at her began to
collapse we thought it was just a
technical glitch an easy fix so we sent
a team of Mobius agents inside but then
we lost contact with them and stem went
dark think about this mr. Castellanos I
am providing you an opportunity nice
absolutely I see your daughter again but
to save her life something you thought
you failed to do before
you can save her or let her die oh
thanks for the choice it's your choice
you know what [ __ ] you wanna see I'm
gonna climb into one of your dirty
bathtubs and and go find my daughter who
is a brain now and I'm just accepting
this or whatever good luck Sebastian and
please try to cooperate with any team
members you might find him there right
okay
yeah sure you don't trust us but they
have the same goals as you do no I'm
probably gonna shoot him in the face I'm
fine by myself just remember to call me
the moment you find Lily so that we can
begin the extraction process huh I'll be
out here for you yeah yeah I don't think
I'm out of Mobius to begin with like
that's how it's got to be right like
Castellanos has to be oh I'm glad in
this wonderful future worth it all in
the brain they still have you as B ports
are you ready
be careful in there Sebastian of all the
things like that
Sebastian should not do mr. Castellanos
please get your head together you've
been looking for this person for three
years then they suddenly show up because
they want you to see them to one and
then you you you know in your head but
your daughter is gone but you suddenly
have a dream about your daughter I know
you couldn't save it right before Kidman
shows up and tells you that the only way
to save your daughter's to go back in
this machine to rescue her from this
fate to pay up to it's all [ __ ]
Sebastian you should know better
I've been falling for 30 minutes this is
Bo oh okay I'm crying upwards now am I
in the middle of a markiplier video
there's so many tears in here okay I
believe this no where am I going now
this doesn't look good this reminds me
of the big hall of baby heads Oh title
sequence
nice
boy
I mean of course there's a certain level
of like acceptance to get into it you
have to like accept to certain things
this guy
Sebastian Castellanos is very very
desperate of course but I don't think I
don't think that Sebastian was ever out
of the stem system in the first place
number one like that's that's no good
number one like the technology levels
that they have here is just very basic
that looked like Disneyland I'm not 100%
certain about that oh it's a hospital
it's Beacon Hospital all right sue the
barn this seems to be a lot of elements
of fire because in the first game every
whoo-whoo in the first game I remember
that uh the the main guy what a ruthian
or whatever it was he got burnt in a
barn fire to be tied to fire you have my
memories huh if that's the case then
where my wife and child
this place looks like my old office at
crimson city Biddy
your self mattress that built it you
should ask yourself that question let's
get down to business we sent some
information into your room these guys
right here cuz they're part of your team
there are photos of a bunch of Mobius
agents here your lost team why so your
experts need rescuing - thanks for the
vote of confidence why would they make
this mod like the the horrible like
futuristic mind prison that is this
place look like a small town straight
out of Silent Hill why would they choose
to do that that's a horrible has anyone
ever been to a small town I grew up in a
small town it's no utopia let me tell
you Valley true this picture of me it
was burned up along with everything else
in the house okay alright my first
commendation feels like another lifetime
yes because it was I don't know about
that alright anything else here my
jacket can I have that coat the coat
looked good on me look damn good
anything looks good on me admittedly I
don't know figure I don't see anything
Union of course not Union huh looks like
any town USA exactly calm and relaxed
the exact opposite of be control it
doesn't seem like you've got much
control this time either look I don't
know what you're going to encounter in
there if you need information
I'd suggest you try talking to some of
the locals you know canvass the area
just like you taught me back at kCPT
for a real detective kid
okay sure all right whatever I got
talked over to all this stuff and now me
we're all stuck inside stem I still
don't understand why you can't just take
them all out of their pods and wake them
up it's the matrix
Moby's has got some stellar backup plans
but why is that my responsibility I'm
the one who already mourned the loss of
my daughter Baker team leader uh-huh
he's the guy I should try to find first
why why him why why we'd why I guess
that makes sense I guess combat
specialist huh hopefully he can take
care of himself
you'd think that all of them would be
combat specialist considering they all
seemed to be like either ex-military or
some like of that psychology and
surveillance this one could be Katie hmm
all right fine Matt one last attack but
at least he has some small arms training
uh-huh
okay why don't they all have small
office training I'm stuck there we go
our Liam O'Neill Liam Oh Irish was not
even expecting trouble if they sent in
all these technicians I guess that's
true that could be what it is yeah if
they expected everybody just to be
technicians but I mean in what world is
this place even reeked of technicians
like what IT guy is gonna go into stem
hey Larry climb into the bath tub of
milk and go into this brain oh boy I
don't know
remember owning a cat I remember a cat I
remember it cat very much hi candy how
you doing
Oh know if that was Kidman's cat that
was rice like projector in the in
Kidman's
dlc thing when Kidman was doing the
thing why is it covered in blood all
right fine
okay slide projector excuse me kitty go
away I put this up on the screen of
blood okay ah back yeah you know the
uncanny valley where things just look
creepy if you look at them that kids
smile it's a dead demons mild I ever saw
one all right I guess that's all of them
right okay talking getting you there you
always really if your damn machine
didn't go on the fritz I would have
spent the rest of my life warning her
and you wouldn't have cared
I cared I'm not sure I believe you to
manipulate me to get me to perform like
a good little soldier these babies to me
before all friendship was built on a lie
yeah you'll never know how I feel until
you've lost your family okay
better to have loved and lost is that
what you're saying taken okay all right
then well that's bat and that's bat
everybody's got emotional baggage just
get over it I'm guessing it is that
brain goop is this some sweet brain goop
oh it's been so long since brain goop oh
it's corrosive it comes from dead
enemies that's cuz it's brain goo thanks
Kitty forget this your brain goop Kitty
all right
oh I didn't do that in there
just like bacon there should be a way
out okay yeah I seem go but we just make
regular doors yeah you know what I don't
know about that one
same terminals I'm gonna need a lot of
these because we're on nightmare mode on
this one and it's just not gonna go good
but I
I'm already on chapter 2 hey I got
through chapter 1 with flying colors I
didn't even need to worry about no thing
nowhere and at least I got a radio on me
just like a real detective here we go
again into the looking glass oh that
would have been a better name for this
video into the looking glass is such a
good name I can change it I'll change it
later anyway so we're gonna get brain
goop and we're gonna put it in our brain
and our brains gonna be bigger and
better don't ask how the cat got that
you don't know you know I know how the
cat got that a few too many chomps to
the brain Euler region of another enemy
[Music]
mom can fix it for you she can fix
anything
yeah yeah no I'm not insane it's on
nightmare mode because it said if I like
the difficulty of the first game then
I'll like this mode and I did like the
difficulty of the first game because it
was infuriating to the nth degree
oh good
clearly not lady be more praying goop
I've got a wonderful family an amazingly
smart and beautiful life why wouldn't I
be alright
whoa there Sebastian whoa there mr.
Castellanos
Oh Oh careful I've fallen into a many
hole before usually doesn't end well for
me oh I get the feeling that combat is
about to start
wait this looks like the house from
Resident Evil 7 am i crazy about that
wait I'm not crazy am I same flooring
same doors a little bit a little bit not
a lot but a little bit ooh I don't like
that at all I don't like that at all oh
my god it's the Cirque du Soleil show in
here where's the ribbon dancers oh I
don't like that hello this is all a
little disconcerting very disconcerting
in de de all right hello
okay all right I'm gonna yeah I'm not
crazy
I'm not cry a mime absolutely crazy I'm
going under presenter what is that what
me well actually probably look oh ah oh
this place no yeah you're right resident
eNOS it's a lot like resident eNOS this
place isn't so awful at all it's totally
fine what the hell did what well that
didn't make much sense that don't make a
lick of sense alright well alright let's
go back through the door then okay I
have a body mounted foot hip mounted
flashlights the most utilitarian of
possible flashlight locations okay
I don't think be tableau is gonna help
me in this certain circumstance sir or
madam boy you know it's always a good
time in classical music starts blaring
out from a inconspicuous and dark
hallway
nope don't like that not one not one bit
no I didn't like what I saw in the
window what are you so uh one of the
search team Baker
what is that why did it reset like that
what the hell that might be the craziest
thing I've ever seen
good god no no don't not not didn't want
to touch it I don't like that I don't
know I wasn't there was a camera out
there Oh God Oh God
let me stop and step out of that real
quick and look at this
oh geez who who did this
ah that's horrifying that's horrifying
I'm sorry
Oh God oh god that's so weird okay well
weird leader a good observational skills
Sebastian real detective Lee worked out
Castellanos oh geez
[Music]
whoa God is like is his mind like
trapped in that one moment of death like
in perpetuity cuz that's awful
that's awful oh that's so bad and I'm
gonna turn up the the game volume just a
smidge hey there we go
alright back to the game yeesh my
vacation was great it really was it was
good to kind of like relax and get away
from things and then eagerly anticipate
the return of coming back to things such
as the like as this also I want to
mention that as of right now as of
exactly right now there are brand new
shirts available for sale with this
awesome holographic logo you may have
seen me wearing similar shirts in some
of the van videos that I've been doing
but if you go to markiplier comm right
now you'll see some sweet sweet shirts
both in the small print and the Big M on
the front something Bad's about to
happen hello I'll take this please ahh
file mystic whoever did this must have
enjoyed it
nothing on the back alright okay you Shh
so who in here would be sadistic enough
to do this because it seems like there's
other pictures on the wall and also some
dirty gloves over there I'm thinking the
doctor from out last one is something to
do with this what I wasn't looking at
that oh it's great B's block the way out
okay all right well I fixed that one no
I remember some timely shoves back in my
day I gotta say though the graphics in
this one versus the first game are
vastly improved it's amazing what
happens just a few years but uh yeah
it's pretty cool Oh does your hand hurt
after three years your hand still hurts
buddy don't you get over it yeah this
I'm not crazy this is this looks a lot
like the house from Resident Evil 7 and
I know that's probably not intentional
probably all decrepit manners look a bit
similar but uh I don't know something
about the rule hello Castellano speaking
these darn pranksters they're always
calling me up in the middle of the night
right before I get in the bath nothing
whole lot of nothin over there a lot of
something over here boy hello why can't
I go in there it's it's waist-high I
can't possibly get over that alright
let's go upstairs hello hello Oh
wonderful painting
Oh God is that just dead either body
parts are ahead I don't know which oh
good the red room upstairs all right
thank you tutorial really appreciate
that
preciate that and appreciate you
congratulations truth-seeker thank you
for taking our spiritual acuity test
we're pleased to welcome you to the next
level of knowledge please report to the
nearest mu Center with this letter to
ascend from probationary applicant to
the position of MU disciple this lever
guarantees you the exalted position at
the next cleansing therem ceremony
handwritten on the back
lies all lies and a symbol I'm sure that
symbol is gonna come up in the future
all right well got that now that's fun
for the whole family
what is that grand is that like the
Grand Hotel or something like that maybe
hey I don't wanna
Hey okay goodbye what's going on here I
don't know what's going on with you okay
all right well see ya yeah have a good
one whatever you do and whatever life
you live that's what you do can I sit I
love this chair
Oh chair for looking out on this ominous
hallway this way whenever someone comes
up the stairs I can go boo and stab them
with a knife and then I'll be hilarious
and get them good all right carry on to
the Red Room the Red Room everybody
everybody like the red oh good another
spooking chair Oh another chair to go
boo and then everybody who walks by will
go Oh God
hello and then I'll carry on my day
knowing that I brought a little joy to
people's lives world needs more spooky I
think this might be another spooking
room I have a good I have a guy this is
definitely a spooking room boy
oh boy oh boy don't trust that hello you
oh no that's the opposite of good ah you
took my idea as terrible as terrible
nothing it ooh
space to enter cover ooh all right that
was to move all right you didn't see
nothing
sir no ye oh ye oh ye ye how very
suspicious yeah good thing I got all
these couches Oh
good bye was that uh he's got a magic
camera well I guess he's powerless if
you just don't let him murder you here
and such a poor guy though good God
just like the search team member well no
the search team member was shot in the
head there's clearly a knife to the
entire torso
get it together your detective all right
moving on boy I love this red room this
is really nice
oh god what is this don't like any of
this I mean I'm one for Modern Art and
all that and modern architecture which
of which this is impossible by the way
out of here yeah good luck with that
when you got the Mobius strip of stairs
going up there and all these clogs you
never know what's gonna happen over here
oh wait no oh no tonight you'll be
dreaming I'll be sitting in a spooky
chair
everybody just imagine me in a spooky
chair popping out from the shadows just
all right and then something's down
there oh no that's the cover I got it
they'll never catch me hiding behind
this chair
we'll get him real good he may have a
camera but I got a boo-boo okay all
right anyway I'm gonna carry on like I'm
not an idiot all right so I can't see
anything down here worth Cleto
Hey don't do that don't do that don't
don't do that don't do that
dannion oh no that's no that's not good
how did blood get all the way up there I
wonder I wonder before I be torn asunder
hi hello someone in there who's in there
all right whatever you say okay
oh now I can climb over obstacles oh
okay three of 40 is I'm collecting most
of them oh jeez it's just another angle
oh no oh my god well lit and InFocus it
looks like a gun was used to shoot him
in the head it looks like oh my god it
looks like you stuffed a hand grenade in
a skull oh yeah ye this person ain't
cool but then again like you do know
death doesn't really mean the same thing
in this place like these people might
not actually be dead I mean they
probably are but considering there's
been a lot of weirdness I wouldn't be
surprised if Jojo walked around the
corner and haunted me from the grave
yeah that's what I think about that oh
boy this I don't like no that's the
opposite of what I wanted on my day here
today
ah nope okay all right then well I did
Li hummed oh where are you gonna go oh
geez I can't go there alright well I
like the placement of your spooking
chair it's very good would have got me
if you had been sitting on it but you
chose to be a spooky eye the end of a
hallway yeah oh thank you
Oh clunk Oh indeed oh very nice ah huh
can you stop moaning for a second I was
observing how much I love this pendulum
it's a really nice decorational feature
and very soothing when you listen to it
that's awful whatever I'm looking at I
don't even know what I'm looking at but
I hate it why is it you're so high oh oh
no that's a neck ah I see what it is now
and it's even worse than I ever could
have imagined oh no just no look if I
had to pick I'm gonna go with no I'm
gonna go with a big old no alright is it
the only way to go
seems blocked off over here I can't
possibly get over here it's impossible
it's uncrossable alright fine if I climb
up the pendulum I might make it right
don't even think about it
oh my gosh yeah my sec I ever able to
teleport everywhere that's the weird
things
oh no the shirts aren't limited time you
can get them whenever you want and
they're gonna be there so check them out
go - markiplier comm they're really nice
by the way I mean I know like it's what
the Frick just happened
hey hey
you guys listening out for me right you
guys are gonna warn me if something bad
happens oh this guy's just sleepy that's
not so bad or dead I got mad why did
that happen I saw that you can't fool me
i SWA why no no no no no no no no no I
don't I don't know about no let's go
with no I'm gonna go with no on that one
yeah oh oh whatever that is it's awful I
don't like it Christ you know what this
reminds me of via in the original
BioShock that guy the guy in the theater
the guy who like froze people
no don't like that no not at all
rebirth okay yeah sure rebirth rebirth
oh no wait that's too many ARMs wait I
don't trust you at all
this looks like an arena no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no oh that's
what opened up okay all right ah good a
killing box hope there's a spooky chair
in here I don't trust that at all I
don't trust that at all I don't trust
that at all at all well that's the thing
right it's it's it's beautiful in a
really horrifying gruesome way art it's
kind of like a dissonance of emotions
like oh the presentation is so nice oh
it's bodies oh it's all bodies
oh it's pot ball but the composition of
this and the lighting is ours corpses oh
god it's corpses you know like that
whole thing and that's kind of what gets
you
oh the use of flowers is wrong
I don't like this room I didn't like the
last room and what the sweat off my brow
no no this room is literally the worst
this is the worst room I've ever seen
please don't come to life and spook me
[Music]
no oh you moved you moved your mouth
why'd you move why'd you move why'd you
move
you didn't need move and you moved I'm
closed off oh no no no no you're not
gonna kill me and take a pic of me no
I'm gonna bypass your [ __ ] here all
right right right hey sorry Oh No
okay you know what I'm not gonna do that
I see what you're doing here
trying to funnel me in for a good old
kill I know what you're up to
Oh God
nope bad yeah I don't I knew it I knew
it I knew it I knew it
he got me got me so good those darn
photographers wait so what happened
where did it go where did it go mm all
right I don't like it oh good a mirror
what am I taking oh it's my pick I look
like a handsome son of a [ __ ]
genuine surprise on my mug hey no hey
all right no I don't know oh my god oh
it's you what happened to you oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh no oh yeah yeah
yeah you're horrible I mean you're
beautiful in a horrible way
it's like oh look a pretty eyes corpses
bats all corpses everything about you is
corpses crap yeah yeah
can I look behind me Sara way to look
behind me if I just run like the hall
that's how you do it
yeah hello okay goodbye
the vault you're gonna kick that door
open Lebowski
yep oh god where did I go dick pick
captain no I'm not you don't know that
oh boy wait was this Oh or maybe no way
to take the most time in the world
possible to climb up that not like there
was any urgency
Sebastian I've trapped it here but
there's no way out baby not like I don't
know why that was so funny to me though
just like oh that's fine you're fine
you're cute you're not my giblets not my
giblets No
all right okay all right okay all right
here we go it's all good I'll give him
everything's fine I think I got away
from her I think that I think I got away
from her this time I think she's gonna
be gone forever I think she's really
going guys
guys I think - uh-oh here it rude rude
rude okay I can't run anymore which is a
bad sign
but okay I'll go down the uh-oh nope
nope don't like this no I was why did I
go calmly run run you big [ __ ] imma
turn around huh I'm looking back I'm
looking back I'm looking back oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
hey no no no oh no no no no no no
[Music]
I'm struggling I'm struggling I'm
struggling I'm trouble take that yeah
how'd you like that knife to the face
not so good ain't it yeah all right
excuse me pardon me hey I need some
healing juice to put on this wound I'm
never gonna be able to survive that I am
NOT rubber nacht I very clearly survived
oh that was my shadow I was like excuse
me
automatic health regeneration when your
health is critically low the life Cades
will turn red while the life gauge is
red it will automatically regenerate it
up to a certain point it will regenerate
more quickly if you stand still so try
to find a safe place to hide and recover
when in critical condition oh good no
probably need that oh but at least I get
a knife all right wait how do I get it
how do I use the knife well how do I
have it equipped okay all right then
nobody get in the way of my stabbing I
gotta find me a good spooking chair so I
can get him in and just pop out from the
shadows and be like yeah I got you
he'll never know what hit him no I mean
after I hit her now where am I
she'll know that it's a knife oh it's
Daredevils apartment the origin of the
medication in these portable syringes is
unknown but they provide moderate health
restoration
it's beer LSD it's crack it's heroin
all of the above shove it inside you who
cares where it came from it feels good
so why not this place is like bad
lessons oh yeah I'm in here now
Sebastian Castellanos detective with a
knife yeah everybody want to mess with
me Journal an abandoned house the hand
written in handwriting in this journal
is neat and precise the final entry
reads as follows just got the call now
another reason for all the weird [ __ ]
that's been happening the last few days
it's the worst possible scenario but at
least I don't have to pretend anymore
the things I've seen they've all changed
it's too late to save them it's time to
put my training to practice
may God have mercy on their souls and
mine is that mr. small arms training is
that what I'm seeing over there I think
that might be mr. small arms training oh
yeah hey there Sebastian Castellanos
have to kick down that damn door again
well here we go how about you oh sorry
this one needs a more gentle touch
apparently hmm Oh convenient ah my
favorite book gun never you and I needed
you I should have been reading that's
what they say that's what they always
say I got a read more a gun
great maybe this is the right place
I do need goop juice I think she's out
there I'm pretty sure Kidman's Lily this
photo I thought it was lost to the fire
forever I remember when we took this
Lily's breath smelled like cotton candy
Myra
never looked more beautiful but what
about how she betrayed you at the end of
episode one about how she worked for
this whole corporation do you remember
that at all
Sebastian Sebastian Castellanos mr. mr.
mr. lon Oh Stephen Goodman I don't know
there's a killer running around in here
doing things that are all over again
what the [ __ ] did you just send me into
yeah
why is this plant glowing oh okay it's
collectible an herb and herb this is
Silent Hill it's so Silent Hill
oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
alright now it's three it's like the
weapon oh oh let's put you it let's put
you at six oh that's good alright maybe
you should be one but I want the knife
to be one not that the knife is an
option maybe the knife is like always a
default although how do I use the knife
very confusing but at least I got my
stab a knife so if I had to oh how do I
get my knife out how do I do it
hang on I gotta where's the where's the
controls here we go
wait well a button assignment no type-c
what is it keyboard bindings here we go
where's the knife sneak kill is F got it
putting this all on my brain right now e
e this game is so scary
e good where's the knife where's knife
there's no knife option male what doing
stupid what is this what is what I'm
pissed
alright I need to find a button for
melee attack because I'm gonna need that
not just Mouse one freaking dummy all
right how about what have I got well we
got left
ER q skew being used gives not use let's
do Q alright male it's cute for some
[ __ ] reason melee its Q alright bye
happy with that it is nightmare mode I'm
doing promos yeah yeah I'm a queue at
the ready yeah oh wait maybe I can bind
it to Mouse wait hang on everybody if I
hold on your pants things are about to
get wild in here alright instead of Q Oh
mouse for who'da thought mouse for was
even a button but yeah alright now I
always got that I got my gun oh you
think I'm gonna shoot ya
stab took a little longer than I thought
it would but I got it
alright let's get on the way not being
silly [ __ ]
[ __ ] didn't mean to get so uncie li
that quickly like this geez well who
left you to rot like this and Here I am
I'm gonna leave you to rot like that
goodbye sir
I'm certainly not gonna clean it up
don't worry Sebastian it's just a small
town oh yeah yeah too quiet
Oh too quiet I Love You Sebastian
you're so right hey oh no no no no hey
she was speaking in multiple voices I
don't like that there's a clear sign
that might be dark applier over there I
think she turned gray when the lighting
changed a little bit when she went
forward a little bit turned a little
gray oh this is bad hello I can very
clearly see how bad this is you see all
the bad
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're very clearly not want to waste
that bullet your we don'twe to mess it
up the oh boy oh boy oh boy that ain't
good
I should have said something cool
they're like you finish your supper see
here's your dessert like god I should
have said something cool god damn it
we saw here it goes wait I must say i'ma
say it wait damn
wait you forgot you forgive you forgot
about dessert ah there we go
cotton sack but stab I'll take that
juice you're human
let me scrape that off the ground there
oh that's not good okay you all right in
here buddy
you very dad how dad are you on a scale
one two dead oh oh oh that's not good
allow me to find a safe haven next to
this a horrifying TV it's like the TV in
my van thank you thank you for that all
right well whenever they get in here
I'll take care of them tree I'm doing
nice dinner
I've got plenty of food all right I
guess they're not gonna get in here I
thought I thought that was the whole
like circumstance that was happening
that they were gonna burst in and
there's gonna be a problem but oh well
oh yeah oh I got oh no the spookin chair
fine I'll be in this chair help me in
this chair you guys go on go on
good job all right whatever
stupid jokes stupid all right going
upstairs doodlee do I go on upstairs
doodly-doo melee yeah come on I want to
really Whangdoodle these things I think
that door so strong
Oh bullets oh yes please thank you very
much okay let's reload this bad boy but
I'm gonna try to get by with just
stabbing for a bit because I have a
funny feeling that I'm gonna run out of
a stabbing or I'm gonna run out of gun
stabs in any moment here hello oh who is
it God right when I get in the tub of
boom Oh get stabbed but yeah yeah oh
that's not good can I struggle you
forgot about this up god damn it you
forgot about desert it just doesn't feel
as good then Jesus
alright fine whatever come on I want to
really loose key those things let me
really let me really Whangdoodle him
alright fine I guess cuz we know how
this is gonna go
alright hang on one second
Oh boom okay one stabbing no no aah dot
and bam pop oh you forgot about we have
no food left
aw Frick
[Music]
alright I'll stop goofing around I'm
sorry was it alright
for realsies this time okay a new
tutorial it has been added is it a
tutorial not how to be an idiot what it
is you know what I'm probably gonna do
I'm probably gonna run by it because I
don't need to waste bullets I think and
oh god my health is low what right whoa
hey I wasn't ready for you
oh god I'm just gonna run Jill Repp BAM
[ __ ] okay I'm out of here
you alright excuse me alright don't run
out of stamina oh that's not good woah
you're a little speedier than I thought
you'd be
dinners in there dinner's it served in
there take a ticket oh whoa
alright hey excuse me
I know how to mail a thank you very much
alright hey yeah
twelve centuries old and still just as
effective I don't believe that for a
moment
hey yeah I forgot about the whole
break-in thing bread flour
Oh Pocket flour I meant to bloom of
smoke when exposed but can I just like
have that in my pocket and what
someone's at my door I'm just like ah
like when I get my sneak in chair when I
get that all set up think that's I know
he's got goop juice in them but maybe I
just can't afford all right you know I I
guess I'll go finish him off
hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy oh he's
gone All Right see ya okay never mind
all right we're gonna carry on anything
in this car we got well okay I'm on top
of it now which is not my intention but
here I am anything in here Oh climb well
all right that'll be convenient to know
oh it looks like Silent Hill we're glad
you're here no no it looks like a brain
that trees a brain the trees the brain
trees brain that tree is brain good well
let's get into this horrible place I
know how to sprint
is there anything hidden in the woods
that I should know about what now
is that small arms training I hear oh
[Music]
oh well that was your first mistake oh
he's so well trained
oh no he wasn't trained hard enough oh
geez not Liam Oh Irishman well that's
good huh no no no no no no no no squeeze
squeeze squeeze
ah okay I got it I'm gonna sneak kill
this person here oh you're gonna get
sneak sneak Oh nope yes ah you're too
far away I should turn off my flashlight
how about that
alright well someone's gonna get sneak
snogged
all over get ready for a sneak in net
I've been sneaking now I've been
snacking that you guys better watch out
cuz the snick snack is back oh yeah I'm
gonna sneak kill somebody you guys you
guys watch out of that unaware enemy
right there's about to get a face full
of media oh yeah
oh he's chopping on the emo Irish boy
over there
peekaboo wait no uh God uh here's your
appetizer Oh oh that's no no no no no no
no no no not what I wanted no one heard
that
doner that ha ha I'm behind a fence
you'll never find me oh man a stamina
cool herb
oh that's not good where is he
oh it's right there okay let's see if I
can lose him I don't know if I can oh
good I gotta get this goop juice oh
sweet goop yeah oh sweet there's a lot
of goo
it probably that's a lot that's it funny
pranks we're all pulling on each other
here just like this hilarious prank I'm
about to pull on your neck
yeah here we go here comes the prank
somebody get the camera I'm about to
pull a hilarious prank on this guy
never mind there we go sparingly all
right this guy he's volunteering to be
pranked how good hey what's that no no
dude dude listen all right it's just a
prank bro oh do you like the bruschetta
there we go
I think all my kills should be
food-related all right
you read this there was something in
that van and there was something on the
dumpster I got to grab before I get out
of here
carry on ooh do I have to nobody listen
to this yeah no nerd that no climate a
little old victory climb let's give me
the Gunpowder all right and then there's
some bottle of something over here it's
just a bottle it is literally just a
bottle that would have been incredibly
useful for me to have right before
everything else happened dude this guy
have a gun on him is that what the deal
was for this guy oh no no this is this
is Billy every teen this isn't actually
one of the members of that club there
all right let me take care of this guy
boy I sneak slowly I sure hope I can
upgrade my sneak in speed just like what
my spookin speed this is spook mode it's
not sneaking mode it's spook mode the
soup of the day is herb lentil
there you go there you go
anybody else if I can get like oh this
guy didn't have any goop juice he didn't
like the soup all right is there any
other that I could get like a freezie
kill now there's probably too many out
there all right I'll just go in here
I'll come back for him it's like it okay
never mind I won't kick it real good I
got oh they weren't there before that's
weird oh I'm so strong hell yeah
but if I slap my hands on this window
it'll work all right well that was
awesome in hilarious I love when games
are unintentionally hilarious all right
let me hang on I think I might have to
think I might have to engage spooking
mode to get over here
[Laughter]
funny to me but this tube sneaking over
this lamp down this way
excuse me that's not funny
oh did they break in watch out for the
lamp it's a doozy to sneak over oh jeez
I'm sorry that's really not funny I'm
sorry
Shh into my gun okay
Wow Wow whoa hey calm down
don't shoot Lin it's me I'm not gonna
hurt you see Oh Danny Boy the pipes the
pipes are calling you can lower your gun
I'm on your side
you're not Mobius
you might not be one of those things but
that doesn't mean you're on my side
you're right I don't work for Mobius but
I was sent here by them try this machine
with those things out there what they
can do
No yeah I have lucky for you your
partner was willing to sacrifice himself
so you could escape think he was willing
he was just a member of Union security
detail protecting me
was his job and my job is to solve a
hardware issue dying inside here is
above my pay grade I'm not a soldier I'm
just a technician I know
stop
all right well Liam sorry that went that
way but it had to be done I like your
soldier would have taken the safety off
ha ha ha
Ricky miss told you we're on the same
side let's try this again I'm Sebastian
Castellanos oh no no that's not right
it's Castellanos get it right next time
Sebastian I'm O'Neill Liam oh no it's
Liam Oh iris oh I'm sorry
Moebius but they sent you in here why
I'm looking for my I'm trying to restore
the core just like you are yeah good
luck with that mm-hmm I'm done I'm just
gonna hold out here until extraction
they can't extract you not until Lily is
found it was Lily look everyone is stuck
in here until the course okay can you
help me out if you're asking me to go
out there with you you can forget about
it this is a safe house so I'm staying
safe got me but I may have a lead on the
core I detected some signals nearby that
resonated the course frequencies got
opinions we were trying to track them
when we got attacked here listen to this
it sounds like a little girl right
was that her the car I think so but I've
been picking up all sorts of weird
signals on my communicator since we got
here no way to know for sure until you
track it to its source how do I do that
your communicator can pick it up too
once you're out there check it you'll
see you'll probably pick up other
signals while you're out there it
wouldn't hurt to follow them to find out
what no way the core first it's the only
way we're getting out of here
suit yourself let's pair up our
communicators that way I can tell you if
I find anything yeah okay
can't hurt I guess sure all right why
wouldn't they be oh oh I love trees ah
some of the stronger eggs are pretty
tough takes a lotta ammo to get them off
my back you got something stronger in
here stronger ammo here but bigger
bullies I'm out there this place was
designed to be peaceful but Mobius and
firepower go hand in hand weird about
where I can find some of this firepower
it's a pretty chaotic out there you're
not gonna find a pile of heavy-duty
weapons altogether but I did see
something useful next to an abandoned
APC just outside I'll mark its location
for you but be careful there are a lot
of those things hanging around it all
right let me let me turn up the volume
real quick because I think it's still
just a tad quiet let me know if that
gets too loud but I don't think it will
be alright so opinion first before I
move on to the other stuff here I have a
distinct problem with him not knowing
who Lily is and not recognizing the name
Castellanos considering he's in the
bathtub where right next to the bathtub
on a big plaque and big bold letters
says Lily Castellanos it's all a ruse
it's all a lie I don't know this guy's
ignorant or untrustworthy O'Neil makai
Rashmi I'm not gonna give you my
potatoes and not gonna happen
there's no way that he didn't know the
name Lily going into this thing if he's
a technician of this thing then he knows
how it works right
he would know that there would be a lily
inside and it's not Lily inside they're
using that to make Sebastian
it's more dangerous out there than I
expect that's my theory any idea kit
mean is actually weapons and supplies I
tried to tell you about this one signal
but you didn't want to hear it well I'm
all ears now I picked something up from
to Mobius security team members who were
talking about weapons caches maybe you
can follow it and get some gear maybe
they're out there can help you out now
let's think about it come on man I'm all
alone in here I could use some
protection maybe if you hadn't let your
last guard take the fall for you
whatever we have to signal on your
communicator whatever follow it or don't
follow it I don't care Wow O'Neill okay
all right excuse you
oh that's cool live members of you it's
like it's like sub mission forces
greenie in here to help us but yeah
there are five search team members wait
did you just say were I found Baker he's
dead huh doesn't surprise me he locked
onto a powerful signal and went to
investigate I told him we should just
request extraction and report our
findings leave the dangerous work to
somebody else but he wouldn't hear of it
being team leader and all always had to
be the brave one [ __ ] oh there's a
thin line between prudent and cowardly -
tomato tomahto I'm not saying I'm great
tomorrow with what kind of [ __ ] do
you think I am I hope the others are
okay I'll let you know if I find anybody
else
why couldn't they've made him say potato
pudding so you've been stuck in here a
week already has it been that long
damn sometimes a little fluid in here
this is supposed to be a simple
in-and-out job like home in time for
dinner simple but this is different than
anything I've ever seen before
what do you mean wonky stuff usually
happens when a core goes AWOL but what's
happening is more than that this place
is falling apart of the seams we use the
stable field emitter but it's not
working like it's supposed to what's the
stable field emitter if Mobius since you
in here shouldn't you know this stuff
already uh we're not gonna talk about
that also did you guys notice how his
nametag it says Mobius on it but instead
of like Mobius it says like with the way
everything is over it looks like mofo
like if that's not if that's not
foreshadowing something or trying to
paint them in a certain picture I don't
know what is I must save here plop this
bad boy in their new slot please yeah I
didn't mean to that but alright double
save for double security rule number one
of the zombie apocalypse double tap or
something call the method of health
regeneration is a good old cup of coffee
that is freaking hilarious I didn't need
to use that health thing if I'd have
known that there was a cup of joe
waiting for me around the corner excus
takes a while for another pot to brew
takes the edge off it really stitches up
these bullet wounds God this knife in my
shoulder feels a lot better now
god I love this game I love it so much
that is freakin hilarious I love it I
love this game
alright Wolff crafting or weapon upgrade
all right let's see what crafting ass
bullets are always good I could always
use that I don't think I have three of
those but I have a lot of gunpowder
what's that
spicy gunpowder down there of the farty
variety all right let's make some
bullets how about just three ah yeah
let's do that
I'll probably need him okay that just
made three bullets
it takes three stats so much my weapon
upgrade what do we got here
ammo capacity fire rate I don't have any
weapon parts so I can't do any of this
but yeah that seems pretty similar to
the last one the crafting of items is
cool because I don't think you were able
to do that before field crafting icon
from the arsenal to craft items without
a workbench field crafting requires more
resources than crafting at a workbench
and you cannot upgrade weapons of your
field crafting
that's handy all right I can assign it
to a shortcut apparently let's put that
bad boy eight let's put that bad boy
eight oh I can't set a shortcut oh
that's stupid I'm gonna set this bad boy
at one get all my bottles in one so I'm
really wearing doodle I'm out there
willy-nilly at random Oh weapon Bart's
oh sweet
I'm still not gonna upgrade prolly well
let's see if I can give me a bunch what
excuse me I'm gonna just there's one
corner of the benches all I'm really
gonna work on let's see what we got I
think fire power would be the best
application of this 90 90 90 oh all
right I can't upgrade anything right now
I'm going to save it until I know
exactly what I should go for you're not
gonna go for anything so high yeah hope
no one heard that excuse me not what I
meant
yeah all right so let's see what's going
on over here
hey Liam who is that there's something
weird out here you know what I'm gonna
go for it hey I'm Eric I'm Eric come
back look at you real hard you got
coffee in there really use some cup of
joe who is that my wife again my wife
this is leading me into who a sneaking
chair a broken chair oh you got my
portable spookin chair Oh finally that's
not good huh so we'll do it that
supposed to mean this is the goop juice
chair not good oh I made a horrible hair
oh yeah I know you oh you could craft
bullets in the old game yeah hey let me
out of here
no oh no you're not my wife detective
Cassady Janos what a pleasant surprise
welcome back you again
how are you here I could ask you the
same question regardless it's nice to
see a familiar face even if that face
has seen far too much you don't know how
much my face is seen detective no I can
help you get back in shape don't like
where this is going
just like before thank you
okay just like before where's the coffee
play into this can I get some soup
really could use some hot hot soup Oh
athleticism that's what I need pretty
much everything stealth Oh my spoken
skills can I upgrade my spooking skills
oh no that's what I wanted but it's just
one away no enhance spooking is right
there ambush my super spook ah my grabby
hands brow brow lured you I'm gonna be
so good at spooking oh man I can't wait
predator spoke inator
I'll pay the full spooky oh man I can't
wait that's exactly what I wanted okay
I'm saving up for the spook oh man
that's so it's not it's not at all all
right I know I don't even need to look
at anything else
hey lady hey lady this place give me an
idea what's going on you it's just like
beacon but this isn't beacon this is
Union is it it all seems familiar to me
these walls that chair you for me it's
as if nothing has changed at all is this
what I brought in here my office is
relaxing but it's no place to loiter all
right I find that now am I ever going to
get these nails right didn't you keep
interrupting my manicure uh don't you
think it's time that you moved on to the
task at hand no lady no I know my off
all right fine whatever okay all right
well I can't upgrade so I'm a stand
save the goop in for another day I need
a lot more juice where's all my brain
goo bat anybody want to give me brain
goop did I get any more slides I don't
think I did no I don't have any more
slides I don't think anything else would
have spawned in the air I don't think
there's any reason to go back in here oh
but one of them is deceased two of them
actually aren't they wait who was the
other guy oh that was he did say that
there was a security detail already in
here so tip of the knife is a dangerous
job yeah and he's dead now anyway I have
a very dry sense of humor let me cook my
way into that mirror by cat buh buh
don't kick you all right let's go back
in here but keep moving forward is she a
program that I don't know she might
actually be inherent to the stem program
I mean just because she has like she
remembers me doesn't mean anything at
all there's definitely some pooping
potential out here all right let me put
on my scooping shoes okay let's see if I
can find this signal
okay let's go for this suck it up James
we've been through worse than this and
we're better armed this time or at least
we will be once we read the supplies
come on
that must be a signal O'Neill mentioned
James what's this one looks pretty far
away but it's the only lead of God if
it's any one not that Lily I'm gonna get
there and then turn right back around
because it's just [ __ ] alright I'm
gonna go for the road signal first all
right back into spewpa mode yeah all
right sounds like that's that that's
disconcerting everyone keeps in her up
in my spooking mode I got much mooking
shoes on
problem or advice you go in that
building and tell Liam pick Irishmen
that there's a bit of a problem out here
Oh Sebastian look out Sebastian no don't
do it oh boy if it keeps breaking apart
like this there won't be any Union to
search yeah try to find that signal and
I'm gonna take my time all right i'ma
take my time
hey lamb uh you might be dead in like
two minutes
just just fair warning whoa was that
hello I'm under here hey what's going on
in here Oh coffee
Oh gunpowder ah blue glow and gunpowder
I should have known okay there was
something going on in this church I want
to make sure no that's where the other
signal was let's go to see it was uh
whoa now what about this other one what
fallen Moebius operative do I have a map
or anything no I don't it's all from the
communicator and there's some herbs here
all right Oh i spooking mode engaged
whoa why is there an glowing yeah damn
bottle okay how do I approach this go
get my bottle out first and foremost
okay so the angle of approach for these
spookin has got to be as thusly
I don't think a head-on approaches good
Oh what are you doing up on that roof
get off of the roof stupid boy oh you
have an ass I want that
oh I want that real bad oh there's
something on you whoa hey hey Wow okay
all right well convenient convenient
I'll say convenient Oh press tab oh
that's so Andy oh there's a Mobius
operative in there are so Andy okay
thank you thank you thank you all right
I'll come back for that it's gonna get
this whatever is here do you have a gun
on you gun three bullets three let me
Pat that ass real quick ah good bullets
excellent oh that's right wasn't that a
thing like all the corpses like
eventually you can just like you can
slap them real hard and search for more
ammo and stuff like that wasn't that a
thing I'm pretty sure that's good good
dog all right what do we got here that's
weird anybody in here
Mobius hello hello Oh another bottle oh
maybe there's a way around back or
something Oh what the hell excuse me
while I dig around in the trash for a
bit there better be a bullet in here
nope Rock stupid did I'd get a rock I've
ever gotten a rock is that over there
hey what's that over there
another bottle perfect okay so there
might be saw way in up here please
excuse me
roof ruff up on the roof
anybody up here I got a bottle anybody
want some huh maybe this is it good got
to put on spoofing mode hey buddy
hey buddy hey buddy stop no don't like
that where you going now you're too far
away to get spooked
oh no you might turn around I've been in
this situation many times before lady
sir all right okay all right okay all
right no stupid piece of [ __ ] I know I'm
a loser
hey boat engage sneakin hot sneaks
knocked he's stupidly you don't know
where I am all right okay oh yeah where
you go Wolfe
I have no idea where she's going okay no
no aah see I knew it was gonna happen
okay here we go all right
[Music]
don't you notice me
how could she have noticed me Oh where'd
I go that's weird
[Laughter]
I'm sorry that was terrible it was
terrible terrible performance from start
to finish just awful this is a sniper
rifle oh it's broken god damn it
with the proper parts that could be
repaired but previous owner is no longer
able to say where those might be found
okay
barrels toast but the rest of it looks
okay need to find some parts to fix it
oh geez so funny so funny okay a
communication log found on the
communicator we're on the roof of the
building next to the visitor center I
blew out the barrel the sniper rifle
need replacement parts stat the parts
are in the supply shed across from the
Union auto repair that's all the way up
in the northwest corner of town it's
right on the edge of the break come on
man I don't care where they are bring
them to me before these things find
their way up here
[ __ ] man why do I always got to get the
dangerous jobs oh come on
McCoy even though probably both of you
are very dead oh wait a minute is that
where is that no don't throw a bottle
there silly Billy okay alright well got
more handgun bullets can i Pat this yeah
I think on you alright fine that one are
you guys really saying that one one
monster zombie lady thing was able to
take all of you guys down alright
whatever I want a bunch of wimpy these
Mobius guys they ain't very good they
ain't no Castellanos that's that for
damn sure
I know I know
no it's not funny it's it's not funny
I'm laughing at completely unfunny
things but that is that is my want in
life and that is what I do but before I
carry on any further
unfortunately I'm all out of time for
today but don't worry because I'm gonna
be back tomorrow with another live
stream of this fresh at 8:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time is when I'm gonna
be starting these things I love this
game so much this game is so fun it's
everything that I loved about the
original and more like I think I think
it's slightly self-aware too because
it's really cool and I like it a lot so
I will be back tomorrow thank you
everybody so much for watching this are
this will be uploaded very soon and
don't forget there are brand new shirts
available right now if you go to
markiplier comm you can find them there
this awesome pocket holographic print of
this cool M logo and also there's a big
one where it's all over the chest if you
want that tons of stuff check it out
double save just for safety thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I don't see you in the next video
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye guys bye bye
good bye good bye